oh
we met up with zach king and challenged
him to do 10 of our favorite table
tennis tricks for those of you who
haven't heard zack he's making the
craziest magic tricks and illusions for
over 100 million followers you should
definitely check him out each trick that
we do gets harder and harder for the
last trick i've got my own little
illusion is that cool stay till the end
we're going to try and get as many shots
in 10 seconds as possible let's go for
20.
oh boy
[Applause]
i think that was good all right that's
trick shot one but they get way harder
they get way more difficult knock down
the rackets
i think we can get it in uh three tries
i brought my friend aaron from aaron's
animals we're ready okay three tries
three two one
oh it's right there
aaron do you want to join from kennedy
you guys have an opening
oh there it is
there we go it's the buddy shot
i'll give you as much stock spin as i
can which is gonna be a lot of top spin
okay
it just goes
down yeah it's because of the top spin
oh closer
oh
there we go oh that's wild they're
getting harder if you didn't notice yeah
a ghost serb what's a ghost serve from
here oh
then you get it okay
yeah yeah a little more spin
that's it oh oh
okay
[Music]
oh
there we go
that is how you do the ghost serve
everybody make sure to subscribe to
zac's channel to learn that to learn all
the trick shots around tonight i'm ready
around the net
oh
that's deadly let's spin it around the
net
yeah
[Applause]
more forward
yeah that's closer
[Applause]
we finally got it around the net okay
you have to roll through with a
skateboard and hit the shots on okay
nope
[Applause]
we got it 50 attempts later they're only
getting harder from here
if i receive the server i get a sensei
t-shirt yeah yes also i notice these are
called the sensei if you guys haven't
picked these up on the merch store you
definitely gotta do it
[Music]
what is going on here
i'm not gonna be able to return it
i didn't even see you hit that i am so
confused
it's so hard that's just an easy step
that
[Music]
oh there it is all right this is the
next trick shot this was your first
viral trick shot you just put this one
shot up on the internet and it blew up
exactly that's how it pretty much
started for us it's an honor to be
carrying on the legacy
oh
he's right there
oh wait that's the flame
oh
there it is no way there it is oh you
usually want it to pass through though
huh incredible good job way to go for
you guys the counterweight infinity this
is the last shot before my illusion
trick shot i'm gonna serve a serve that
spins around to that side and you're
just have to hit the moving ball how
does it sound sounds 20 times more
difficult than what me and aaron were
doing
it shouldn't be it's instead of nine
[Applause]
this level is no joke
oh
we got it we got it wow
that was incredible skill and accuracy
on both our parts incredible part mostly
luck incredibles but uh that was that
was exciting that was good all right
this next one i've got a trick for you
guys and we're just gonna play a regular
game of table tennis sounds easy yeah
here we go
that was one of the most confusing
things we've been part of it was pretty
well huh that was crazy remember to
check out zach's youtube channel in the
links below
until next time
[Music]
where did he go